hello everyone I am Mattel hi and their
talk is called building applications
with the new online repository
welcome everybody if you've been to our
knowledge repository last year that was
Tyrell fantastic neural networks and
where to find them this is a little bit
more application oriented so it's called
fantastical networks and how and where
to use them which doesn't make any sense
but whatever so okay and this is not
line of the talk so we start with poetry
which showcases some so we will we will
show some new models we have added and
then we'll show some application which
were built with these models at this
year's war from summer school and then
we'll go for some live training using
some of the models of the repository so
- [ __ ] I will start with showing the new
models so the initialization Celsus
which we will deal with later but again
this is a Harry Potter themed
introduction to the neural net
repository so this is Nimbus 2000 and
it's 30 years of mathematical and 20
years of Harry Potter so let's also
celebrate that so anyway and from the
theme of the dock so anyway we have the
new model which is an improvement to the
existing ResNet models and these makes
them accuracy go higher and the training
faster so that's the improvement or the
improved version of ResNet here and
correctly it's identifying it as a broom
and you can do so the best thing about
the neural network repository is you get
these output as computable so what we
call the knowledge base we you get it
like a computer computable form and you
can query about other properties and
here we have the query of the definition
so it just gives you what's a broom is
and it's linked to the entities which we
have so other than broom you can also
query about the top
probabilities of what else it might
think it to be but room was a good guess
here so let's move on so the so in
feature extraction models so we had all
the glove models before so now we have
contextual board representations so it's
just not looking up table for tokens
it's actually produces the embedding
that depends upon the context or the
like where the word is used in a
sentence so we will try to show that
with an example here so the models there
is Elmo and it's a fairly complicated
architecture would take you along ok so
the person who build L was there such
arrow is there and he's pointing
something and well he he has a talk so a
main part of this talk was to introduce
you to all the models so that you can go
and attend individual talks so that was
also there I think I have written it
here so for more information on natural
language processing we have Jerome
stocks so yeah and then it produces
three distinct thousand and twenty four
that's the size of the embeddings
produced here and let's so yeah this is
the architecture of Elmo and again these
are pre-trained models so the
architecture is brought and the weights
are brought so you have it all ready for
use and here we take so here is a again
this piece of code is directly from the
repository so you can just use it to see
embeddings and obviously elmo is amazing
and so it's J wrong there so we just we
just took the elmo is amazing sentence
and we are just mapping the dimensions
of these embeddings as we said there
were three vectors two of them where
so I think two of them.the
context-dependent one is not so yeah
that's what we are getting the
dimensions of but the best part about em
both Elmo that was missing in the glove
models is that it refined the
semantically nearest word so that's
that's actually what I wanted to show
you here so here if you see I am trying
to find the semantically nearest word to
play and he or it says Harry received
the Nimbus 2000 in the first image so
that he could play for the Gryffindor
words so here it refers to the act of
playing or game and then the sick so I
am comparing it to two sentences where
we are seeing that it's a two-stage play
so more like a theater and then
Quidditch is a sport that is played at
Hogwarts so essentially if it was not
semantically it was not nearing for the
contest looking for the context it would
have guessed play closer but if you
actually evaluate this this piece of
code you would see that it finds played
that refers to the game that refers to
the context that the word play has been
used in the sentence so that's an
improvement or that's what brings meteo
will show training like how you would
train we use this model so now let's
other applications so the image
processing we have added a network that
increases the resolution of images so
it's a very simple linear architecture
that's inspired by vgg and it takes
these low resolution images and does
some kind of up sampling so this is the
net so it's the VDS R as we refer very
deep net for super resolution so we take
an
image and this is the scale or zoom or
we are going to zoom it down by this
factor so here we are going to do two
ways of upscaling one is using the VDS R
and the other is just using traditional
image processing tools and so here we
are just using that by reese image
resize so let's now compare these two
results between the you know neural
network so that's an upscaled and the
naively upscale which is not that naive
but yeah but image processing upscaling
so here let's just use to compare the
results so here you see the naive
version of it and hopefully you will see
the difference between at least in the
edges you will see the definition has
increased one thing for all of these
networks since it's it's trained in his
own factor of 2 to 3 so it's best used
in this zoom scale so that's so then
again there are these series of cycle
gans that's there in repository that can
take a photo to a van gogh thing to it
or money or I am not good so there are a
series of cycle cans and then you can
make oranges and apples and zebras and
horses so I am NOT your why you would do
that but but you can do that using these
models but
you
no it's it's no no it's it's trained on
yes yes most of these mobile training
are very large collection of images
comprising everything yeah yeah yeah I
mean it really depends on what the image
what the network was trained on so it's
like so for example that that model like
horse to zebra that would sort of photo
diversity into a lot of zebras if you
give me the photos of a cat that there's
no idea what a cat is
yeah I mean you have to think about the
domain the network was trained on and
and stay in the domain as long as you do
that you're fine and most of the network
are trained like for example image
classification networks have trained on
millions of images across a lot of
different classes and so on supported
zone
some are very general purple some are
quite narrower but in we depend on what
the initial target so yeah one point
something million images like the full
image net is 14 million but so yeah so
this one's just getting the style of Van
Gogh and the previous image that was
loaded but okay so again there are
series of cyclic ants let's go to the
yeah so let's go back yeah you see there
there is one of the bullets it doesn't
need matching pairs so it's it's another
technique so this is so one important
premise maybe it wasn't clear but most
of the modern is about it was not were
we're not created by us
these are reimplementation of the
external models like mainly coming from
academia so this particular one is our
implementation and yeah so it's it's
based on these fancy technique which is
actually which is called cycle again you
can look it up there's a paper it uses a
adversarial training and the nice thing
is that it doesn't need matching pairs
with that so you can throw at it a bunch
of real world images and a bunch of
paintings and you can learn to map that
is also I mean there are locks all these
like weird so for example maybe summer
to winter you could do it with matching
pairs because you can take the picture
of the same place but like ours to zebra
you cannot do it right you cannot play
take an exact picture of horse and that
take away the tours and put a zebra in
the same exact position for thousands of
images and a collection of a picture and
that's it so so now I'll come to the new
sections that's added in the repository
so there is semantic segmentation models
that have been added quite recently and
then we have nine of those so I will
just take an example of one and show you
so this this model was trained on
cityscapes data and it's really
important for self-driving cars and so
this is so here we will take this model
give it an image of diagonally because
that was the closest I could get to far
the cityscapes data so that's the image
and then there is this function result I
can say what so the function generally
it does that pixel by segmentation finds
out what classes are there so it will
delete so it will find out different
classes and then place back colors do
the classes and do each pixels of the
class and then finally give you the Oh
the image the mask the overlay stuff the
mask on the image and then it will give
you the labels what classes it found so
all of these stuff is defined in the
last slide that magic result function is
actually defined in the last slide there
is an association code yeah it does find
certain things that's not actually there
like there is no bed for some reason it
found a bit but that's but that's that
was also not trained on so there is a
whole section and there are different
models that's a train on different types
of data so the cityscapes data and then
you have the famous Pascal walk and the
MS cocoa data sets so next I will move
to another new section that's language
modeling so these networks were actually
trained here at Wolfram research so
there are different models trained so
I'm showing the English character ones
but then there are models for C and
JavaScript that you can use for say code
completion so it will autocomplete the
code
so here we are trying to just exemplify
one of these models so here we are
taking the character level language
model it means that it just tries to
predict the next character given the set
of characters you are feeding it so and
so again this generate sample is the
magic function that's there
at the end of the presentation so in the
initialization cells so I am just giving
opps okay there is something wrong with
the let me just try to yeah you weren't
supposed to see that yeah so yeah so
here we are generating sample with this
Harry P and it just finds it just
generates a random piece of text but but
it doesn't do such a bad job because
whatever is generated given that it's
just generating one character just it's
a character level model if whatever it
generated makes sense at least to me
says Harry Potter said in the pool a
senator and there is a factor here
that's the temperature sampling so if
you play with this factor so let's just
do one one more rerun of the same thing
it still makes sense but if you increase
this temperature sampling it will
essentially sample from a wider
distribution and you will start getting
more garbage or characters that are so
you'll start certainly generate samples
from a wider distribution you will start
getting improbable characters while it
generates the function and that's crazy
so you have point four is a good
estimate or narrow enough distribution
to get a good answer so now let's use
the same model for auto-completion
and so this is again a chunk of code for
auto completion Auto completing words
and here I have taken the names
of my favorite characters in that order
and try to make it autocomplete the last
names
well Harry Potter seems to be very
popular on the datasets Wikipedia that
it was trained on the Severus Snape
Albus Dumbledore was not often used but
a good thing to notice is that whatever
second names we are getting they are
valid second names so they are not that
it just learned a random word it's sort
of guessed that it's a name and a second
me amend it guess is quite good second
names so again there is a talk for NLP
there is a hands-on session for NLP and
then there is there are two other talks
where all the different functions that's
there in neural networks for nearly
Network frameworks for NLP and
separately there is N and P talk as well
so this is another section in the
repository that's speech-to-text so this
was the this is the deep speech model
that's a trained on English data so
again this model consists of convolution
layers each for time and frequency and
then it has different gated recurrent
units and then finally it is using the
beam search decoding and then this is
essentially this with some other
fanciness is made in speech it's the
back end for speech recognizer that will
be there into health so this is the
audio clip let me play the audio clip I
just reloaded oh I think I have no but I
think audio could not be maybe maybe we
come out from these speakers yeah maybe
you can
you are a wizard honey so and meteo
could not guess it because of my accent
let's see what the network does and we
were trying it to the money and he could
not yes
that's human versus AI right here so
that's that's more or less all the
section there is another section for
object detection but we have
presentations for images from again
respective say they'll talk more about
but here because it's harder to train
train custom applications without a GPU
and data set so we initially planned
we'll make it hands-on but then the
maximum we could do is make a cat dog
classifier with images so we thought we
will just take use cases from students
who had spent you're sorry a week a week
or one and a half weeks in summer school
and these are all projects which I'm
highlighting from there so they it's
just made in one or one and a half weeks
time and so we will go over the
different tools that we have to make
custom applications while we discuss
these projects so the first one is image
classification so this one is used to
classify plugs in connectors and then we
will so this is the model that he chose
so this project was done by Rishabh from
Boston University so he chose this model
because it had the maximum performance
the highest performance although that
was this is kind of the largest of the
models it surrounds 440 megabytes so
here what he did was to take the
relevant layers so he's taking all the
layers until
here so the negative three he's just
dropping the linear layer and the
softmax layer that is what you need to
drop when you are making your own
applications because these were trained
on imagenet competition data so there
are thousand classes of images there so
when you are making your custom
applications you will not have the same
classes so so that's what you what is
done here so it's taking all of it until
those linear layer and softmax so these
are the classes of connectors and plugs
which so that's the list of it there are
32 of them so this is this is
essentially all network surgery
functions that you would use to make
your applications so here what we are
doing let's go one step at a time so we
are pre pending the this cut sections of
atom model so you are not taking till
the last
we are just dropping the last three
layers so it last two layers essentially
so you can also do net drop for that for
that part and then we are pre pending it
with the image augmentation layer and
then after that we are adding the two
layers that we removed but now we are
adding it in a way that so the softmax
would take the length of the connector
list because we have put a decoder that
has the classes given by this list so
essentially that's the network surgery
that we have done so if you can if you
go ahead and see these are all
uninitialized that's why it's grayed out
so there is the image augmentation layer
that we prepended then we have the
entire thing from the my atom net and
then and then essentially appended or
like joint the last two layers so that
holds for network surgery and then the
final section is how you would train it
we are not training it how we do
have the trainings that so this is
essentially how you would train this
surgery model but yeah so you would you
read model so that's the surgery model
and then you have the training set and
this is what is called like you do
transfer learning using learning rate
multiply so that's the function in
Wolfram language so what we are doing
here is we are changing only the waves
so we are just left
letting the last few layers learn so
anything beyond 6a is learning and
everything above 6a is kind of fixed so
beyond we are not letting anything above
6a learn again this is an experimental
thing you need to do and see which one
gives you the best results but he found
out that everything towards the end of 6
so the previous layers are fixed to the
original values from your digital models
and mostly you need large data sets so
this is the pre trained model from the
summer school and we will see works so
one thing to mention is that this
project took like one week but they were
done by students which were learning the
language learning the theory if you know
what you're doing you you can you can
make this thing in one day basically
next model so here they have again he
has he was doing a rooftop recognition
to find the solar energy potential so
again it's the atom the same model that
performs quite well and the same
principle as in like we are dropping the
last three layers and here we need to
resize to the initial image
sighs that we are feeding so we are
feeding 500 cross 500 images so that's
where we are
resizing so changing the in like
changing the net encoder and then
finally we are joining similar to what
we did last time so this is the original
this is the original net we dropped the
last three layers we need to put it back
customized for our application
so this is how we put the thing so we
are just putting this stuff back again
so this is done via net join and then
you're just taking the first part so
let's go again the same principle holds
we are not training it it was trained on
well-known dataset so we are importing
this trained Network and let's go ahead
and see how good or bad it works
so this is again taking the Geok
functionality in our net in our
framework taking an image resizing it to
a nice zoom level because you need to
match the zoom level to the initial
training trained networks and see what
the training set was how your training
set images look so after doing that so
this is so all it needs is the latitude
and longitude so I fed in the latitude
and longitude of champagne so this is
don't know which water champagne is this
but yeah this is some image of champagne
I let the detector so the trained net
run on this image get the mask and then
we can do a similar thing overlay the
thing so this is the action image this
is the mask and then we just overlay one
thing over the other so it's pretty much
great
so this is so the network was trained on
a date I said that we got publicly it
was a publicly available dataset but for
testing we are just using images that we
are downloading from geo image so yeah
yep so I'm afraid this won't go as
planned because we were so I was
supposed to be some training now and we
were supposed to use my laptop which has
a GPU but like freaking out were
connected to the projector for some
reason so this laptop doesn't have a GPU
and so I think we'll see I regularly use
an external monitor with that laptop I
really have no idea why okay so yeah so
I will attempt to show a retraining of
our language model on Pokemon means to
create a Pokemon named generator this
was inspired by some okay there is there
is a blog which which does all these
crazy experiments you can look it up
it's very fun it does things like
training language mods on cooking
recipes and so on
it's called unison quark it's a tumbler
yeah anyway so so we gotta retrain our
warfare language model from scratch so
this is one of the models for which the
architecture you use for training is
different from the architecture used for
evaluation so here I'm getting the
training architecture by specifying that
such an argument here which is training
that and what this thing does if you're
familiar with language models this is an
architecture for teacher forcing
training so this is the actual network
we are going to train the input is fed
to both of these ports we take the most
as in the the most
action of the both language and the rest
of the descent of the input sentence and
compared the predictions from the
network for each from the following
character of each character in the
string with the actual next character so
this is this is called teacher forcing
so we have the architecture we can get
the data from the entity system and it's
just a list of Pokemon names
okay now we see so this took one minute
on my laptop but can take a crazy amount
of time here 29 minutes ok these these
will not come in there even if you train
for half of the time it would still be
too bad so it's not really about how
many but it's more about which GPU you
can print in general you can paralyze
across different GPUs and the more you
have the best but it's not like user you
use a hundred GPUs and again 100 times
speed up so I mean it it's a very
complex business in general because it
depends a lot on how large your data set
is if you have a very tiny model with a
tiny data set there is basically no
point in training on a cluster of 20
super powerful GPUs because their
performance will be basically the same
as training on one single laptop GPU so
it really depends on what your
application is for this is a reasonably
I mean you can also call it a very light
weight training so it will take 1 min I
mean we're the training set is one it's
like 800 of these strings so that's
sleeve this is length
data oh of course it's raining okay
let's just stop this
so it's 900 so it is a very tiny dataset
yeah if there is enough time we could do
that Pokemon means yes so so the way a
language model works is that a language
model is a system in which you input a
string and and the language model
predict what the next token of the
string would be you can have both
character level and word level so you
can predict the entire word a completely
single character is a character level
model and you know if you if you
feedback what you are already predicted
to the input you're just writing things
right these are a language model works
so this is basically learning the
structure of this data set which is how
you aliy a Pokemon name looks like or
sounds like whatever it is and so that
is what is attempting to do
unfortunately this will work very bad
and we will output random garbage but I
mean on my laptop the results were
actually pretty I mean pretty good it
was like very yeah Pokemon is names
yes
exactly yes and so technical little for
this you've seen I have I have appended
a full stop after each Pokemon named a
generation time I use that full stop to
stop generation so it's like when it's
rain I input like I pick a letter at
random and a central Network keep
generating until you hit a full stop so
okay so now we have our train or let's
say badly trained teacher processing
architecture so now we have to extract
this guy from here and perform some
surgery so what we need to do let it
let's see so this statement we extract
this part which is that from language
model we have to train and we have to
make some modifications but actually
this predict comma one so it's this part
okay it is a bit technical but so the
main point is that when you train with
teacher forcing as you read the input
string you have to predict each next
character as you read the string why at
evaluation time you only have to predict
the character next to the final one
because that's what you're interested in
too so these I mean this code here is to
modify this architecture so as it only
predicts the character next to the last
one and not the characters next to next
to each character as it written string
so you can see the final the final
structure takes a string as input and in
the output it outputs a probability
vector of size 97 which is basically the
the number of characters in lowercase
alphabets uppercase alphabet and some
punctuation that's what it is
it will still generate that that's the
point in this is not about trying to
copy stuff from the data sets this is
about learning the structure of data
sets and keep going to extrapolate of
course if you feed the beginning of an
actual Pokemon name from the data set
you have very high probability that the
network will just complete it because
but but I mean that's not only supposed
to use it of course you don't want to
call them no there is still an infinite
number of examples any number of ways
you can complete that but as the network
reads it it basically sinks ok this
looks a lot like what I've already
learned so I am very confident that the
right next character the correct next
character is the actual next character
from the name in the data sets yeah
definitely yes yeah but that's because
in most of the Pokemon means after Peter
was fouled yes
so I'm actually not you know language
models are a kind of tricky I'm not sure
if they actually will qualify for
supervised or unsupervised maybe maybe
she omits um some hints about that so
basically in a language model is you
compare your input with a label but you
don't have to actually label data by
hand because the label is the actual
next character from the string so yeah
it's like so the question is does
language model training qualify as
supervised training or unsupervised
training yeah yeah yeah it I mean it's
that there's a fine line between
supervising and supervised training in
this case
good question yes yes because you can
assign basically you can assign probably
a probability to the whole string so if
the probability is high then it yeah
this is how these are how language
models are used to improve
speech-to-text applications so when
you're speech-to-text model you have a
network which reads audio and spits out
characters but that networks doesn't
really know a lot about written language
so after that you can refine that step
by having a language model read that
string and if it finds some for example
the speech-to-text might output a
misspelled word right the language model
is able to identify a misspelled word
because they have low probability and it
can fix it will mean by cypher data
well that's very tough because that's
that it's not like you have a you have a
single misspelled character that's like
complete yeah yes the new function
speech recognizer in 12 we will feature
language model correction
okay fine fair enough
so in that case maybe not who knows but
I don't know maybe wizard in doubt point
is that you you can imagine that in some
the training set for the language model
the word wizard was a pretty much more
frequently than the word whatever that
means and so maybe the language model
could have decided you know I'm not sure
about this let's make it wizard but
sure sure sure sure didn't
yeah but the point is you have to think
so when you go from color to labor to
word level you you you get the problems
out of vocabulary like a misspelled word
will likely not be recognized by a word
level model because there is no match
for that word otherwise the model knows
right yes in that case it would work but
if if you actually say give me a beer
and speech-to-text model will transcribe
misspelled version of the word beer then
a word level model will not be able to
correct it while a curriculum level
model will okay so let's look at the
garbage that this thing will output it's
even worse than I expected
that is eleven point three okay
yes sure okay this was actually meant to
be running twelve but I mean that that's
not a big deal
the point is that did we know maybe work
but the result would be no it's a very
general thing and so I mean here in this
function I was using a syntax which is
all about going 12 to do temperature
sampling inside the network without
having to break it into pieces
basically temperature sampling is about
dividing your so these models output a
probability vector for the next
character right so it with temperature
sampling you before actually sampling
for this vector you divide the the
vector by constant which is the
temperature and if you if you think
about it this means that for basically
very very high temperatures all the
probabilities which will kind of become
the same so the the distribution will
will flatten out and this is what to
[ __ ] up showed when you put in
temperature equals 210 if for a very low
temperature the distribution I mean the
peaks become even sharper and the beeps
become lower and so temperature sampling
is a way to actively modifying the
distribution for each sample every time
so you know I was just using a handy
syntax we introduced in 12 to do this
but this is not 12 but so it was not
working let's see okay this is pretty
amazing actually I didn't expect it to
work this bad okay it's not very Pokemon
but no you know what happened okay
I know what happened I know what
happened it was starting from the pre
train model so it didn't really care
about I sorry so this model was trained
a lot on Wikipedia data and for like one
minute on Pokemon mains
and so what you're getting at is
basically Wikipedia out of this plus
some weirdness okay yeah this is pretty
funny
okay yeah so to shoot a can you run that
and maybe if you get time at the under
presentation we can we can bring the
model to this laptop and and show you
yeah yes there is basically the more
data you have the more stuff you can
afford to Train okay so if your dataset
is very tiny
you only swap the last layer maybe you
keep everything frozen and you only
train that last layer on top of the
other stuff which is fixed the more data
you have the most of you you can afford
to retrain I mean what then the keyboard
is overfitting if you have a very tiny
amount of data and you and you expect to
train the whole network on it the
network we just over fit so it will
memorize what your training set is and
it will perform very bad at evaluation
time on new examples so in general
yeah yeah I mean maybe you're looking
for more quantitative statements the
point is that yeah because there is a
huge number of possible variation you
can add I mean it's not like three
layers two layers it depends on which
layer are we talking about convolution
layers or linear layer or recurrent
layers what the dimensionality of the
representation was the kind of network
architecture as well I mean it's you can
possibly formulate a quantitative of
terms for these things and it's mostly
about trying
I don't quite understand the question so
you were talking about like the
hierarchical representation learning
going on in like they put indications
the answer is they don't know what's
happening
what you mean by distances what do you
mean by distances I understand
[Music]
yeah so the point is usually the the
shallow layers meaning the layers which
are closest to the inputs they're
usually very general purpose as soon as
you go deeper and deeper they become
more and more specialized for the task
so that so that's why when you when you
so for example in the plan in the plug
connector task you take a network train
on image net you will never return the
first layers because image net is a
massive data set of basically everything
and those layers are super general so
they have they have just learned to
recognize basic shapes basic patterns
and colors you'll never need to swap
that you can possibly do better on
something trainer image net right now
for those layers as you move down they
specialize more and more in actually
discriminating image net classes which
you don't care about so that's not the
reason why you should keep the first
well video is a completely different
thing it's a complete different kind of
inputs so I mean one very stupid way
yeah so of course I mean you can always
extract a single frame from the video
that's an image and then we're talking
if not I mean another thing you can do
which is like would be the zero order
generalization from Billa to image is to
extract all the friends classify all the
friends and and combine the results in
some way but that's not really video
processing right yeah the proper way to
live with video would be either three
dimensional convolutions because a video
is like a three dimensional image or a
recurrent layer a recurrent
convolutional or network because a video
is it can be seen as a sequence of
frames and
sometimes you want Aaron and stupid
activities video and not yet not yet I
mean it will it will come at some points
but it's not it's not a priority right
now because you know there is not even
like proper language support for videos
right now you know that sweet some image
manipulation functions for videos it's
about ten people now well for no Lynette
for no net it's like three or four the
the entire machine learning thing is
about ten yes three deconvolution see
are possible in eloquently yes
are you trained and put it on okay which
we will with it ok can you train also
the the other one okay so how much time
do we have
oh great okay okay so yeah III add
another like a live training with Elmo
but there is no time for that and you
already seen this so